很多人都以为盘中那些跳来跳去的价格都是随机的
但我今天想讲一句赤额的真话
为什么你会在股市里赔钱
就是因为你根本不知道盘中该看什么
盘中有超多细节
小到你觉得不重要
但就是这些细节最容易泄漏
阻力真正想做的事情
在影片最后我会给你一个盘中判断表格
你看到讯号就能立刻知道多空方向
所以一定要看到最后哦
大家好我是Mocha
我砖子当中8年了
有过五年,脚水经验带过3000多位学员
为什么盘中细节这么重要?
你每天拎着价格上下而正来正去
但你可能没有想过
阻力所有的动作都会留下痕迹
无档挂单怎么铺成,怎么变化
成交明细的节奏如何变动,如何放大说笑
量突然冲出来,但价格不动
或是关键加位手不手
这些全部都是资讯
不是学学,不是感觉
这就是讯号
只要你把这些讯号拆开来看
你就会发现价格根本不是乱动的
細節1 五檔掛單吃單方向
假設一檔股票單盤整
突然有人開始
連續吃外盤單
不是一下
是連續三次以上
這通常不是散戶
因為散戶比較會排隊會猶豫
所以這有可能是主力
因為主力常常是
看到該拉的位置
直接掃過去
給你一個小訣竅
連續通方向大單
吃單三次以上
就值得注意一下
一節二 成交明細的節奏變化
很多人只看成交量
但真正重要的是節奏
正常是
打 打 打
但如果你看到變成
大大大停一下
大大大
這通常是主力的小單測試手法
在測試熱度
測試力道
或是在偷偷吸貨
偷偷出貨
而且通常節奏會突然變快
但價格卻不明顯變動
這種盤面最值得盯
細節3
真掛單
VS假掛單
市面上最容易誤判的訊號
就是大量掛單
但大量掛單分兩種
假的還有掛真的
分辨方式很簡單
假掛單呢
常常掛出來
又撤掉
用來干擾散戶的
用來測試程式單的
真大單大多貼著成交夾掛
常常一下就被吃掉
吃完也有可能在乎上來
如果你只會看掛單量很厚
就覺得支撐強或是壓力強
或是直接認定這是真掛單
那你很容易就會看錯方向
我自己看掛單手法
八年了整理出四種
主力常用掛單形態
只要看到五檔一至兩秒
就可以直接判斷
現在是偏多還是偏空
或者是盤整
我把它放在下方資訊欄
點連結就可以免費領取
細節4
關鍵價位手不手比突破重要
一般人盯著會不會突破
但老手看的不是突破
而是手不手
阻力真想拉會死守自己的根本區域
你會看到幾種情況
海盤看起來不強
但就是不讓它跌破某個位置
每次跌到這裡就有人接
這種價格就是阻力的底線
反過來如果那個價位跌破後沒人救
那就代表阻力要落跑了
或是阻力剛剛只是在洗盤
這比你看任何技術線都還使用
細節補 突然爆亮 但價格不動
很多人看到爆亮會興奮
以為要噴了
但真正要先看的是
價格有跟著動嗎?
如果短時間爆大量
但價格完全不動
那就有可能是
逐利再換手
或是逐利再調整成本 常為
真正的發動是
量加一期動作
爆亮不動價
就是不要讓你看得懂
如果你聽到這裡覺得
原來盤中是有那麼多的細節
那有沒有辦法整理成一套策略使用呢?
你可以到資訊欄領取我自己在用的極短線當中策略
裡面有無檔掛單分析
成交名系讀訪
完整進出場SOP
會讓你把今天我講的這些細節
全部串的更完整
一開始我說你不是看不懂盤面
而是你根本不知道該看什麼
現在你已經知道
主力所有的動作都會留下足跡
你只要抓對細節
訓號就會自己跑出來
現在付給你今天學到的盤中判斷表格
趕快收藏影片
明天盤中拿出來對照看看
我是摩卡也是你的交易教練
我們下次見